[Music]
the discovery of road and crater
what prompted that I decided it was now
time to go do what I really thought I
should do and I had received a
Guggenheim grant so I used that to fly
all the western states
these are these spaces that are built to
get you up into the sky and then have
some way of viewing this guy especially
when did you secure road and crater
I had the lease on it in 76 and actually
purchased it in 79 uh-huh so that it
took three years to actually buy it but
it wasn't really for sale there almost
some geographic framing devices or yeah
these are geological formations that I
really found perfect for that
[Music]
we're talking very much about the idea
of landscape in your work and earlier we
talked about the idea of the West yes
well the West is also where this work
was formed so this is the work that
aggregation space it kind of came from
the West in the sense that we had much
less expensive space here I'm interested
in this landscape without horizon and
that we're moving toward this new
landscape and living in it
and you better be prepared for up no
down the left to right you have no way
to know which way is up and so you have
to really learn to negotiate this new
landscape that we've moved into same is
true in space and there we even remove
gravity this is the world we're moving
into and it's very much analogous to the
topology and cyberspace we've actually
moved our lives into this territory
much of the kind of language of your
work is about the empowerment of the
viewer this is for the viewer and their
that they actually format I always
thought it was something where I use the
material light to work the medium and
perception